يقع اقليم دارفور في الجزء الغربي من
السودان وتقدر مساحته بخمس مساحه البلاد
يقارب عدد سكان الاقليم تسعه ملايين ونصف
مليون شخص ويسكنه عدد كبير من القبائل
ابرزها الفور والمساليت والزغاوه
والريزيجات وترجع تسميه الاقليم الى قبيله
الفور ودارفور تعني موطن الفور تحد
الاقليم اربع دول من الشمال الغربي ليبيا
ومن الغرب تشاد ومن الجنوب الغربي افريقيا
الوسطى ومن الجنوب دوله جنوب السودان
ينقسم اداريا الى خمس ولايات شمال دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه الفاشر وجنوب دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه نيالا وغرب دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه الجنينه وشرق دار فروع
عاصمتها مدينه الضعين ووسط دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه زاليمجي
يمتاز الاقليم بثروه حيوانيه كبيره وكثيرا
ما عرف صراعات بين الرعاه والمزارعين ردت
الانتماءات القبليه نشطت في دارفور جماعه
مسلحه منها جيش تحرير السودان قصير عبد
الواحد نور وينظر اليه على انه القوه
القتاليه المهمه الوحيده المتبقيه داخل
دارفور حيث يعتمد قائده على دعم قبيله
الفور وحركه العدل والمساواه بزعامه جبريل
ابراهيم وتكونت من مسلحين معظمهم من غير
العرب اضافه الى جيش تحرير السودان بزعامه
مني اركو مناوي وتشكلت هذه الجماعه نتيجه
الانقسام قبلي بجيش تحرير السودان كما
ارتبطت بقتال فصائل جنجويد المسلحه
المتهمه بارتكاب فضائح في دارفور
[موسيقى]